uh one of the things that became super
clear
during the last administration was that
so many of the things that the right
accused the left of doing
they were actually guilty of themselves
and we have a word for this this is
projection you project onto someone else
things about you you accuse others of
doing things that
you were doing and one of those things
was that the left is rooting against
america
and this applied in a whole bunch of
different ways
don jr for example famously said
a couple months into coronavirus i don't
remember remember exactly when it was
kind of i think in that third quarter of
2020 don jr said
the left and democrats are rooting
against the u.s on covid
democrats want people to die of covid
to make donald trump look bad and of
course it was completely untrue
there was no evidence of that but they
continued to insist they also would talk
about oh the left is rooting for russia
the left is rooting for china or the
left is rooting for europe or whatever
the case may be
things have now come full circle and in
the developing kerfuffle between
president joe biden and russian
president vladimir putin we're going to
talk about that more on the bonus show
fox news and republicans and
right-wingers are openly
rooting for vladimir putin now is that
patriotism
when they say america first when they
say pro-america
is this what they're talking about
openly rooting for vladimir putin
this started when joe biden referred to
vladimir putin as a killer last week
and then vladimir putin challenged joe
biden to a debate now
why foreign leaders would debate and
people wouldn't say
that doesn't make sense we'll talk about
in a little bit but let's look at some
clips
they're all rooting against the united
states here take a look at this first
clip
of fox news propagandist sean hannity
who does he
sound like he's behind is he rallying
behind the american president here no it
doesn't sound like it
now question is this why would vladimir
putin immediately call
for a debate with joe biden no time to
prepare
what have i been saying what of some of
us half the american people saying the
media mob in this country
they protect all things radical
socialist joe biden
and his administration hannity defending
putin challenging biden to a debate if
it were trump
challenged by a foreign leader hannity
would say were the united states
nobody challenges us no american
president needs to debate any foreign
leader we do whatever the hell we want
different situation right now here's
republican congressman matt gates
straight up saying this debate would be
all putin if it happened
putin and biden it would not end like
rocky
iv i don't think the american would
prevail
here's fox anchor harris faulkner
similar attitude
saying of course putin is going to
challenge
biden because biden hasn't even done a
press conference
at biden by the way doing a press
conference thursday which i will be
covering live here's
harris faulkner i can't help but think
katie uh just a quick follow-up with you
that this isn't also
the determination that how dare america
talk to us about free speech
when their own president won't go live
with free media like
how how you know what it does make us
look like we're hypocritical
so there are two layers of hypocrisy
here
first is the idea
that this is as simple as putin
versus biden on rhetorical skills
and none of them want to mention the
dramatically authoritarian nature of
putin
the poisonings the killings the fact
that putin
is accurately described as a killer by
joe biden
they're silent on that they won't even
concede none of them are saying
maybe putin would win a debate but joe
biden is right
putin is a killer but maybe the debate
would go putin's way
they won't even say that they don't even
acknowledge
the accurate critique of putin by joe
biden
acknowledging that doesn't mean we go to
war with russia i don't want a war with
russia
i don't know anyone who wants a war with
russia but then
here is the crowd that for years and
years during bush
during trump they say we are patriots
and we stand behind the president
period it's always america first never
second or third or anything and here
they are just saying yeah putin putin
putin no criticism of putin
not even saying biden's right even if
he's not a good debater biden is right
putin is a killer these people are
disgusting
but they're also hypocrites and we knew
both of those things all along
now one last thing i mentioned this
earlier
when has an american president ever
debated a foreign president
in particular at the demand of the
foreign leader what and what i mean by
that is
why are they even entertaining this on
the facts
they ran out of things about dr seuss i
guess if
any foreign leader had challenged trump
to a debate
they'd be saying an american president
owes
nothing to other world leaders no
american president should devote
a second of their time debating another
world leader
the goal posts aren't even in the same
stadium
when the president is a democrat as is
joe biden
so we're going to get the press
conference i'm as interested as anybody
else to see joe biden answer questions
from the press
in a more extended format that'll be
thursday don't know the time yet
but i will be covering it live on uh
youtube twitch and facebook i hope
you'll join me for that
and between now and then in the 72 hours
that remain
before joe biden's press conference uh
we will continue tracking what it used
to be dr seuss 24
7. now it's biden versus putin 24 7
on fox news